bonjour monsieur bonjour monsieur
comment allez-vous cher Monsieur très
bien ça va vous passez une bonne journée
normal
vous cherchez Brigitte
[Musique]
un Macron qui vient de passer
ou pas
nous voulons maintenant des actes on a
entendu sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision
c'est vraiment dommage que ces jeunes ne
comprennent pas les enjeux républicains
et ne comprennent pas la grandeur de la
démocratie vous avez mis la faute sur le
décodage des programmes nationaux ce que
vous avez fait madame la Première
ministre c'est du mépris social toi qui
a vu tous les pays c'est quoi le pays où
on est le mieux où les feuilles où on
vit le mieux
c'est ici mais oui il y a que quand un
voyage et que tu comprends que la France
c'est si c'est pas le meilleur pays du
monde c'est un des meilleurs non
vraiment quel petit mot rigolo peut-on
lire si on tape 707 sur une calculatrice
j'ai pas fini et qu'on la retourne SOS
lol
et puis sinon je veux dire socialement
on a des aides on a des machins on est
on est on est vraiment c'est quand même
super sécurisé quoi plein de niveaux
c'est sincèrement je vais vous dire un
truc et là je pense très sincèrement nos
voisins
il faut pas casser ce pays
le chef de l'État veut-elle vite exemple
cette semaine un décret qui supprime les
allocations chômage pour un salarié
ayant abandonné son poste oh c'est pas
possible d'être retravaillé comme ça
j'ai jamais vu des gens aussi
retravailler Emmanuel Macron a été
accueilli par les Hué de centaines de
manifestants il a d'ailleurs évité la
foule et s'est rendu dans une ville
voisine à Pérols pour rencontrer des
gens désormais l'objectif des opposants
à la réforme des retraites et clairement
affichées perturbé chaque déplacement du
président de la République un millier de
manifestants ce matin à Ganges et une
contestation audible
hier la préfecture vous allez le voir
avait pris un arrière pour interdire je
cite l'usage de dispositif sonore
portatifs
drôle de pique
[Musique]
là
moi je vous dis ce qu'il en est
interdit
[Musique]
on va voir cette photo si vous me
permettez bien évidemment avec tout le
respect mais je ne sais pas si on va
l'avoir tout de suite ou pas la photo
que je voulais vous montrer est-ce qu'on
l'a la photo marine non c'est pas cette
heureuse
c'était quoi j'ai pas beaucoup
incroyable découverte sous les rails du
RER B à Paris une nécropole
gallo-romaine du deuxième siècle a été
mise au jour lors de travaux à quelques
mètres de l'entrée de la station
Port-Royal des offrands des sépultures
et au total une cinquantaine de
squelettes décors qui n'avaient donc pas
été vu depuis l'Antiquité c'est soit
vous seriez déjà des Gaulois
réfractaires déjà
l'un des plus importants mouvements
sociaux de l'histoire du Canada un tiers
des fonctionnaires sont en grève pour
réclamer des augmentations de salaires
et des jours de télétravail cela fait
des mois que des négociations sont en
cours avec le gouvernement de Justin
Trudeau mais elles ont échouées
je vous offre ce livre sur les canisards
donc accessible à tous la résistance
les œufs et les casseroles c'est pour
faire la cuisine
les rois du
monde vivent au sommet
[Musique]
on l'attend leur château
labo il s'ennuie pendant qu'on va nous
on tend toute la nuit ce qui me choque
dans ce pays c'est le degré de
détestation du chef de l'État qui sombre
parfois dans l'irrationalité
c'est-à-dire qu'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui quoi qu'ils disent quoi
qu'il fasse il est conspué il est
critiqué il est méprisé et il lui reste
quatre ans à tenir enfin c'est quand
même quelque chose de grandiloquent les
rois du monde
[Musique]
ce sont des militants d'extrême gauche
donc à un moment donné on voit la
l'oeuvre de l'extrême gauche l'extrême
gauche qui casse l'extrême gauche qui
brise l'extrême gauche qui insulte et
l'extrême gauche qui est une gangrène
pour notre pays moi ça me fait vomir il
y avait pas que des étudiants il y avait
des professeurs qui ont passé
Olivier l'extrême gauche contamine tous
les esprits des jeunes on les a en
tremblant
jetons